get ready to watch amber Rose's strut  her stuff on the dance floor EG has  learned the TV personality will compete  on season 23 of dancing with the stars  it's amazing sources confirm to ET that  the 32 year old is set to hit the ball  room when the show returns in September  so far mother amber is the only name  we're hearing to be locked in rumored  participants including Olympic gymnast  mckayla maroney and Simone biles have  shot down the idea of competing this  year I'm hearing you might be doing  dance with the Stars that's room well I  would love to but the fall season won't  work because we're just so busy with  tour but if I could do the spring season  I would love to do that okay